how do I get my employees to work as
hard as I do my reply on email to make
them equal Partners the way I think
about getting team members on board is
by caring more about their needs than
mine most operators and business owners
think that just because they pay someone
that they should be doing what they want
them to do I think this is an incredible
vulnerable framework people talk about
wanting their employees to be loyal yet
they're not loyal I think we have
audacity at the ownership level at the
leadership level the way I do it is
through empathy and compassion and
putting myself in them shoes and asking
why would they want to be on board I
reverse engineer their emotional graph
and then on an individual basis I try to
understand where they are on their
Journey